好了，各位。这节课咱们会玩得很开心。我叫Apoorv Agrawal，接下来大约九周的时间，我就是你们的讲师。今天我们要讲的内容是……
先简单介绍一下我自己，为什么我会来教这门课。还有一些课程安排上的事。对了，有测验，没错，我就是那个第一天就搞测验的人。而大家最纠结的大问题就是：钱在哪儿？AI里的钱到底在哪儿？
有些人可能认识我，不过呢，我的故事始于印度。后来我搬到了新加坡，之前还碰到几位新加坡来的同学。大约十三四年前，我和苏尼尔还有其他几位伙伴在Palunteer开始了职业生涯。
我领导过各种工程团队。说白了，我们就是在政府部门写了不少Spark代码，然后我回到斯坦福读研究生，也就是在那时，我厌倦了在政府大楼里写Spark。现在我在Altimter担任领导职务。
不知道你们有多少人听说过Altimter，它是一家投资公司。我们专注于相当集中的投资形式，有两个业务：一个上市业务，一个私募业务。然后我得到了
我人生中最大的一次晋升，就在六个月前。我现在是个骄傲的父亲了。人们告诉我，这是我一生中最重要的投资。有些人说这是最保证负回报的投资，但我认为
这是最保证正回报的投资，虽然不是在财务上。但这就是我。我就住在街对面，有问题随时找我。我想成为你们的资源。我还有一位非常棒的助教，叫Khloe Fang。如果有更难的问题，可以找她。
有问题可以问她。
好好利用这门课吧。我们为你们准备了一流的课程。这门课设计为每周不超过三小时，包括课堂阅读，以及你们花在跟ChatGPT、Claude争论它们能不能替你做作业的时间。所以大约一小时上课，一两个小时阅读。基本上，从下次课开始，每节课都会有嘉宾演讲。
就是关于它能不能帮你做作业的争论。所以大约一小时上课，一两个小时阅读。基本上，从下次课开始，每节课都会邀请嘉宾。
按照查塔姆宫规则，很多嘉宾可能会分享，甚至说得过多。所以请不要录音他们说的话。课后我们会有自选的晚餐，欢迎你们参加。Chloe会
安排具体事宜。评分很简单，一半一半。来上课就行。如果Ali都能来上课，你们也能。另一半是课程结束时发布的作业。对，这是互动式的。提问，参与。你参与得越多，收获就越多。说实话，我能从中得到的是，我会从你们身上学到最多。
提问并参与。参与越多，收获越多。说实话，我能从你们身上学到最多。
很多出色的演讲者，一个比一个厉害。对我来说，说实话，编排这个日程是我过去几周几个月的工作。Khloe对此很清楚。但请务必
出席。这些都是了不起的领导者，经营着从半导体到基础设施到能源再到模型等各领域的卓越企业。我们会有来自OpenAI、Anthropic的嘉宾，还有
还有一系列应用和代理。所以请把最棘手的问题留给嘉宾，他们会喜欢的。我们还会布置一些阅读。那么，你为什么要上这门课？你希望从中获得什么？
获得什么才算好？说实话，我想过这个问题，刚才我还跟一位学生讲起这一切是如何开始的。我每年回校园一次，谈论所有正在发生的事情，通常是为了寻找优秀的人才。
通常是在寻找优秀人才的背景下。我意识到这是一个巨大的超级周期。我们知道这一点，Altimter也相信这一点。我们整个重点都放在这上面。
但我没有找到一门能深入讲解的课程，就像我本科或研究生时希望的那样。我想到五年后，每个人都会问你：‘嘿，你当时看到它来了吗？你就在起点。ChatGPT发布时你在场，当构造板块形成、格局变化时你也在场。’我觉得你希望能说是的。
当时你就在起点。ChatGPT发布时你就在场，当构造板块和格局形成时你也在场。我觉得你希望能说是的。
你们中一半人会创办AI公司，另一半会投资它们。所以至少，你们应该知道如何花掉筹到的A轮资金。而且至少，你们会对不该做什么有感觉，或者至少有一些思维模型：当看到某个业务，无论是考虑创业、投资还是加入，该问哪些正确的问题？
不该做什么，或者至少有一些思维模型，比如对于我关注或考虑创办、投资或加入的业务，该问什么正确问题？支配这个行业的物理法则是什么？
在这个周期阶段，这个业务的物理法则是什么？我认为这将是最大的一个周期，很高兴你们能和我们一起学习。我要花点时间在这张幻灯片上，因为这就是要点。
这就是核心观点。你们中有多少人以前见过类似的内容？做了阅读的人，谢谢你们，我很感激。我们也为更喜欢听觉学习的人准备了notebook LM。但让我们
让我们花点时间讨论一下。这里发生的事实际上是生成式AI目前最大的问题：如果你听任何超大规模云服务商的财报电话会议
或者说，甚至英伟达和其他公司，我们投入了巨额资本开支，我们大力建设这些数据中心，就像黄仁勋所说的五层蛋糕，包括能源、芯片、电力、
互连、内存等等，所有这些造就了一个数据中心，你可以按小时或按token租用，用来训练模型和提供模型服务。那么问题是，你构建的这些模型，
是否创造了经济价值？这基本上就是这张图表的右侧。为了类比我看过的最大的技术革命，比如25年前的互联网，20年前的移动，以及10年前的云，
最近的一次是10年前的云，我曾展示过云的类似图表，在阅读材料中你会看到互联网和移动和云的相同图表，云生态的形态与AI生态截然不同。
有人猜猜为什么是这样吗？或者你对此有何理论？为什么看起来如此不同？我们不会称之为金字塔，我们会称之为三角形，一个倒置的三角形。
>> 请说。
>> 是因为AI还处于早期阶段吗？
>> 是的，绝对是。
>> 确实是早期。这是个好猜测。还有其他人有其他想法吗？
>> 也许是因为英伟达拥有垄断地位，所以他们可以收取高价。
>> 下周当英伟达的人在场时，你能再问一次这个问题吗？但你说得对，这是个好观点。他们确实有垄断地位，对吧？阅读材料中有一个图表显示英伟达在计算领域的市场份额，
目前来看，那份额非常高。还有其他想法或假设为什么如此不同吗？
>> 是的，我不知道，云栈似乎能够利用硬件来产生价值，而AI没有真正获得价值。
>> 你知道，我们知道软件如何吞噬世界，正如马克·安德森所说，软件吞噬世界，因为我可以构建软件并分发给数百万人，且运行软件的边际成本几乎为零。这些
软件企业的毛利率高达80%，甚至90%，但AI这种新的经济模型并非如此，因为如果我们有一群用户使用Cursor，或者你听到的那些关于大规模企业的故事，
即使收入达到数十亿美元规模仍不盈利，那是因为AI应用的增量用户并非免费的。并非边际免费，实际上要贵得多，因为
你需要燃烧GPU才能维持AI用户。并且你们说的都很有道理，无论是因为早期还是英伟达的统治地位，我们称之为问题的物理特性截然不同。
推理运行方式无疑是我们目前所处的位置。所以我认为现在的情况就是这样。我想在阅读材料中提到另一个维度，我们分析了互联网、移动和云的情况，
分析了移动和云发生了什么，以及这些三角形翻转需要多少年。其中一个例子是AWS，AWS始于2004年，在2010年有了第一个客户Netflix，
2010年再次，最终亚马逊在2012年全面转向AWS。从破土动工到首次资本支出周期，用了8年。不知道你们中是否有人记得20年前的财报，当时的大辩论是，
嘿，亚马逊会不会破产？那是每个人都关于AWS建设的最大的问题。幸运的是，至少目前还没有人濒临破产，但这些数字很大，所以我们稍后再回到这个幻灯片，
但我要说这是本课程的核心主题，我们将邀请这里列出的一些公司的演讲者，以及其他人，围绕的核心主题是：
嘿，在你们领域，比如英伟达的演讲者，你们是主导力量，你们能保持多久？你们最担心的力量是什么？你们最担心的替代者是谁？
你们业务定价压缩的向量是什么？对于Anthropic和OpenAI的人，我们会大量讨论盈利能力，你们服务于十亿用户群体，在OpenAI，与Anthropic的人一起，
坦白说，这个班级100%都在云端。所以我们会问他们，这群用户是否盈利？你们如何看待盈利能力？广告是否会成为比订阅更大的收入来源？然后对于中间这些公司，
推理层，你知道，这是整个生态系统中竞争最激烈的部分。很多初创公司做得非常好，到目前为止它们正在获胜。但你也看到超大规模云服务商也想在这个层面拥有主导话语权。
这一层。说实话，最终结果还未定，最大的问题是：你是一个功能特性，还是一个平台？很多我们在基础设施方面看到的新业务，感觉上想法很好，但如果你问自己：这为什么不是AWS的一部分？你可能会想，也许它就应该成为AWS的一部分。所以对于演讲者来说，我们会聊很多这个。在我们进入测验之前有问题吗？请讲。
但如果你问自己，这为什么不是AWS的一部分？你可能会想，也许它就应该成为AWS的一部分。所以对于演讲者来说，我们会聊很多这个。在我们进入测验之前有问题吗？请讲。
>> 我很好奇你怎么看待，在右手边的三角形中，应用层很小，你怎么考虑把现有平台像Salesforce这样的包括进去？
也许收入，你会把它们作为分析这个金字塔及其如何随时间变化的一部分吗？这是个好问题，我可能会补充，Salesforce、Palantir，有一系列我们称之为旧经济的公司正在重塑自己以拥有产品，比如Salesforce的Einstein，Palantir的AIP，等等，答案是肯定的，它们应该被包括进去。
旧经济公司正在重塑自己以拥有产品，比如Salesforce的Einstein，Palantir的AIP，等等，答案是肯定的，它们应该被包括进去。
应该被包括进去，答案就是肯定的，我解决这个问题的方法是在计算中获取模型收入，所以如果你是Salesforce，你可能运行一个大型模型或者运行推理。
他们的支出被捕获在应用层通过底层基础设施。从公开披露中很难提取出来，但确实应该包括。
>> 是的。
这是金字塔右侧底部的大部分，基本上是为未来收入购买容量，这些收入将归于顶部，这是我们在成熟的大型科技公司中没有看到的。
>> 这是个好问题，也许我重新表述一下，问题是：半导体层的建设是否存在时间错配？因为通常你建造半导体是为期五年或六年的周期，但应用收入是当前的。这是个好问题，这就是为什么这个三角形下半部分有些周期性，你会经历资本支出周期的阶段。把它想象成铺设铁路。
应用收入是当前的。这是个好问题，这就是为什么这个三角形下半部分有些周期性，你会经历资本支出周期的阶段。把它想象成铺设铁路。
铁路。确实如此，所以在阅读材料中有一个图表，展示了移动超级周期中发生的情况。类似的事情发生了。第一局许多重资本支出业务的市场估值膨胀，所以如果你考虑一篮子资本支出名称，或所谓稳态名称，你应该预期这一点，所以我怀疑我们太早了，这种情况也在发生。
重资本支出业务，所以如果你考虑一篮子资本支出名称，或所谓稳态名称，你应该预期这一点，所以我怀疑我们太早了，这种情况也在发生。
>> 我很好奇你怎么看谷歌，因为我看到你把谷歌标记为谷歌云，他们在中间层，但谷歌也有自己的模型TPU。它们完美集成。你如何看待它在三角形中的位置？
>> 任何像谷歌这样的大型企业集团，我们得按业务部门来分。我会把TPU业务放在半导体层。我们在这里包括它，因为我们计算了收入。他们的GCP单元在基础设施层，Gemini单元在应用层。
基础设施层，Gemini单元在应用层。我们后面有一张图会稍微聊一下，Gemini实际上是最常用的消费应用之一。它目前是第二常用的消费应用。最大的问题是，其中有多少来自谷歌的分发优势，还是它本身就是一个非常好的应用。最终结果未定，但我们会探讨。
最常用的消费应用，它目前是第二常用的消费应用。最大的问题是，其中有多少来自谷歌的分发优势，还是它本身就是一个非常好的应用。最终结果未定，但我们会探讨。
>> 是的。好，我们继续。
>> 我有个关于预测的问题。现在看起来这个三角形交易，如果成功的话，也许应该翻转。但一个不成功的新技术看起来是什么样子？是保持一个三角形吗？你如何预测它是否会翻转？
三角形？你如何预测它是否会翻转？是的，我不确定，也许我重新表述一下你的问题，我可能会说，这个行业的稳定均衡是什么？我认为很明显，AI不太可能是一时风尚，不太可能是一次不成功的尝试。我经常思考这个图表的稳定均衡。
不太可能是一时风尚，不太可能是一次不成功的尝试。我经常思考这个图表的稳定均衡。事实上，我在Twitter上与某位非常聪明、对此思考很多的人就这个确切问题进行了辩论：什么是稳定均衡？我的猜测是，它可能会比我想象的持续时间更长。
他对此思考很多，就这个确切问题进行了辩论：什么是稳定均衡？我的猜测是，它可能会比我想象的持续时间更长。在云方面，我认为那个范围大约是十年。我有一种感觉，这种情况可能会持续更久，因为要正确构建底层基础设施是多么困难。但会有一两个解锁。
十年。我有一种感觉，这种情况可能会持续更久，因为要正确构建底层基础设施是多么困难。但会有一两个解锁。我无法告诉你它们是什么，但例如，如果某个超大规模云服务商的ASIC项目，无论是谷歌的TPU、Meta的MTIA，还是亚马逊、OpenAI、微软以及我们甚至不知道存在的所有实验室，取得突破性成功...
某个超大规模云服务商的ASIC项目，无论是谷歌的TPU、Meta的MTIA，还是亚马逊、OpenAI、微软以及我们甚至不知道存在的所有实验室，取得突破性成功...
我怀疑那将是该层最大的重新定价。另外，另一个催化剂可能是，你知道，我想到了超大规模企业在财报电话会议中的资本支出指引，顺便说一句，我建议在座各位每年听四次，你会听到上市公司CEO们告诉你他们最大的问题和他们正在思考的最重要的事情。
而且，你知道，我建议听这些电话会议。如果他们不再给出大数额的资本支出指引，因为那将意味着当前的均衡不再成立。
因此，这可能是第二件可能发生的事情。你会看到关于所有超大规模企业给出的资本支出指引有很多新闻，原因就在于此。
>> 请讲。
>> 那么，训练和推理之间是否也存在一种优雅的权衡？因为我的感觉是，如果这种方式奏效，推理的规模就必须远大于训练。而且，我很好奇你何时会看到这种情况发生，因为你说这意味着厂商会停止在训练上投入，因为他们没有看到训练绩效的显著提升。
因此，会发生什么？这是一个很好的问题，并且这可能是英伟达财报电话会议中最受追捧的信息之一，即在其业务中推理所占的比例。上次我查的时候，大约是40%，或者说他们透露大概是40%。
这意味着，如果他们销售了一百万个GPU，假设满负荷使用，大约40%用于推理，另外60%用于训练。我怀疑这个数字会随着时间推移而增加，推理的比例会上升。但我不会，呃，我不能告诉你何时以及如何发生，因为世界上仍有许多训练正在进行，而且你们知道，训练工作负载的形状与推理工作负载的形状非常不同。
训练工作负载非常可预测，短期利用率高。推理工作负载非常突发，通常在人类清醒时使用，直到代理接管。也许到那时它会变为24/7运行，并且更难预测。由于某种原因，圣诞节期间会下降，感恩节期间也会下降。
但我认为情况可能是这样，我们至少在这次计算中尝试捕捉这一点，因为这是一个混合情况，但这是一个好的假设。
训练负载非常可预测，利用率高，但时间短。
推理负载则具有突发性，通常在人类清醒时，直到代理接管。也许到那时会全天候运行，更难预测。有趣的是，它会在圣诞节和感恩节期间下降，但我认为情况可能是这样，尽管我们至少在这次计算中尝试捕捉这一点。
这是一个混合体，但这是一个好的假设。我已经看到合并，但利润会在哪里产生呢？
在幻灯片16页上。我们马上就会讲到，我会给出答案。价值链上最赚钱的部分显然是半导体，遥遥领先。
英伟达的数据中心收入，毛利率大约有75%。不过别拿我这话当精确数字，大概上下浮动几个百分点吧。而我估计应用层的收入呢，
差别就看你怎么问了，大概在0%到30%之间。差距相当大。我觉得原因，就是这位先生提到的理论，在于有一个玩家几乎通吃了半导体领域。
事实就是这样。而且如果从盈利能力角度看，这个三角形会更加集中。我等会儿讲到那里的时候会展示一下，但是……
问得好。请继续。
云计算就像是今年的AI。
是的，那确实是很大一部分原因。我们已经经历了云计算的投入周期，这肯定是一个因素。请继续。
如果这些基础设施公司，比如谷歌、英伟达，都有自己的TPU，英伟达也在搞，OpenAI也在找ASIC，那么所有这些初创公司，他们自己的芯片打算卖给谁呢？
这里有3000亿美元的收入可以争夺。但回答你的问题，大约一半来自大型云服务商，正如黄仁勋在财报电话会中透露的那样。所以这些可能是你的主要客户。
如果你今天要创办一家芯片公司，客户基础会非常特殊：少数几个大订单，和大规模客户业务或企业软件业务这种形态完全不同。
企业软件业务，然后你可能会有一些零散的企业客户，不过我不会指望这个，因为我觉得他们会直接去找云服务商。如果你考虑创办芯片公司，这是首要考虑的问题：你先卖给那五家中的哪一家？
这应该是你的首要考量，就是：那五家里，你先卖哪家？
最后一个问题。
我想说的是，每个层面都会产生少数几个赢家。这需要好几年的时间才能显现出来。呃，也许我说得不对，但我觉得过去并没有完全纵向整合的公司。
可能只有一家做到了完全整合。我知道谷歌在右侧实现了完全纵向整合。我们想知道这会如何改变开发力量的分配。
好问题。互联网超级周期中最大的赢家可能是谷歌。它的市值大约三万亿，搜索市场份额接近99%。我认为这算是一家相当纵向整合的公司，对吧？
他们自己管理文件服务器、搜索，上面还有广告，以及用户体验。接着是移动互联网，那轮超级周期的赢家是苹果，市值大约两万五千亿左右。你已经知道答案了。
下一个是社交网络。Meta可能是社交领域的大赢家。但他们的整合度没有那么高。他们的市值现在大约两万亿，已经很有统治力，但也许因为并没有完全下沉到服务器层面，所以损失了约一万亿。
你看，云市场其实相当分散。没有任何一个单一玩家完全主导云服务。三大云计算平台，AWS、GCP和Azure，它们并没有完全整合。而Nvidia一直在努力尝试，不知道你听没听说过DGx Cloud，那是他们构建云生态的尝试。
显然，他们也在尝试一系列垂直应用。所以，是的，你可能发现了重要的一点。大家注意，我知道现在是周四傍晚五点钟，大概是周末前的最后几个小时。我不想做那个扫兴的人，所以我会直接进入让你们精神起来的环节。
实际上，我这儿有个小测验，我们要进行一下。我会给你们一些关于接下来要讲到的公司的提示。
我会给获胜者一个奖品，所以你们有动力。你们可以通过正确和快速两个途径得分。最快的办法是做快速推理，然后把答案上传到云端。
你们可以使用工具，没问题。只要给人类玩家5秒钟的时间，让他们用传统方式来回答。如果你真的想用Claude，也可以，但请给他们5秒的领先时间。好了，第一题来了。
云端。请随意。只要给人类选手五秒时间，让他们先回答，用传统的方式获胜。如果你想用Claude，也可以，但得给他们五秒领先。好，第一题。
这是第一题。
准备迎接下一个。
在座的软件工程师可能有先发优势。
所以，我想花接下来的大约10分钟，讲讲我对当前情况和价值流向的一些假设。
有人问过一个很好的问题，关于盈利和它如何被放大。我们会涉及这个。但同样，如果有问题，随时可以打断我。我感觉时间不多了，我会准时结束。
你们还记得这个。我稍微修改了一下，做了和两年前一样的分析。当时的图表是这样的。
生态系统明显小得多，大概只有现在的五分之一。但令人惊讶的是，它的结构基本没变。尽管增长迅猛，但看看新增的约3500亿美元收入。
其中大约75%的资金直接流向了半导体行业。尽管应用层增长超过10倍，却仍然没有太大改变。所以我想，让我们深入看看。
如果你们打开这些细分类别，探讨各部分的公司组成，你们会发现这3000亿美元中大部分来自英伟达。而应用层，实际上有两家公司占据了90%的份额。
基础设施层是竞争最激烈的领域，正如我们讨论的，这里可能正酝酿着最大的战斗，既有横向竞争，也有纵向竞争。
这里也是新陈代谢最快的领域，很多公司成立，也有很多公司被收购。我认为这是竞争最激烈，同时也是最不稳定的均衡状态。
现在，我们作为投资者思考的问题，也是你们未来投资时会考虑的，就是这个过去两年变化甚微的图表，需要多长时间才能实现形态转变？
它需要多久才能达到云软件的形态？是5年、10年、15年，还是永远不会？也许就一直这样。我们确实认为会转变，但速度不够快。
这不是发生得不够快的问题。第二点，我们思考AI未来时，经常想的是这个……你们是否在阅读材料中看到过这个图表？但消费者……
目前，在编程之外，AI最大的市场是聊天机器人，使用率极高。ChatGPT大部分功能免费，约95%的用户是免费用户。还有Gemini，不知道你们是否留意到，DeepMind的负责人Demis
宣布他们不打算将广告作为订阅收入模式。我们一直在思考：这些业务能发展到多大？它们的变现引擎是什么？你们觉得订阅业务会更大，还是广告业务会更大？所以我研究了AI之外最大的消费者特许经营业务。
订阅业务会更大还是广告业务会更大？所以我研究了AI之外最大的消费者特许经营业务。
你们会看到，这些产品你们都知道。有一类产品用户规模达到30亿，这些几乎是生活必需品，比如WhatsApp和Chrome，没了它们简直没法活。
然后有一类产品用户规模在15亿到20亿，属于社交类，比如Instagram、TikTok和Facebook。它们不是必需品，但有很强的网络效应。如果我的朋友Chloe在上面，我就更可能去那里。
它们有很好的网络效应。如果我的朋友Chloe在用，我就更可能加入。还有第三类主流消费产品，既非必需品，也并非极度社交化，我称之为小众产品。比如购物去亚马逊，听音乐去Spotify，想辩论去Twitter，或者看猫视频。
我称之为小众产品。购物去亚马逊，听音乐去Spotify，想辩论去Twitter，或者看猫视频。你们猜猜ChatGPT和Gemini现在更接近哪一类？
ChatGPT和Gemini现在更接近哪一类？答案在下一张幻灯片，我们很快揭晓。你们猜猜，ChatGPT或者领先的AI应用外部规模，会更接近像YouTube或WhatsApp这样的必需品应用，还是Instagram或TikTok这样的社交应用，还是Spotify或Twitter这样的小众应用？
像YouTube或WhatsApp？社交类如Instagram或TikTok？还是像Spotify或Twitter这样的小众应用？有猜测吗？如果没有，我就揭晓答案。请说。
我认为会是YouTube或WhatsApp的规模，因为它是日常工具。
对，人们日常都在用，成为生活的一部分。
好，让我展示答案，然后我们再回到你的猜测。还有其他猜测吗？有不同意见吗？请说。
更接近Facebook，我认为大概有9亿用户。
对，你说得对，目前确实如此。我展示一下答案。这是它们的情况对比。ChatGPT刚刚超过小众类，而Gemini还没有。你说得对，它正朝社交方向前进。
作为OpenAI的投资者，我原本希望它能朝核心工具方向发展。但我们问自己最大的问题是：知识工作，也就是每个人都在做的工作，是否就是ChatGPT的定位？它还不是一个可以发消息给别人的地方，也不是处理邮件或获取多巴胺的地方。
我们问自己：知识工作，也就是每个人所做的，ChatGPT现在还不是你与人交流的地方，也不是收邮件或获得多巴胺的地方。它是一个你需要主动提问、做积极工作的地方。
你去那里必须做积极的工作，必须提问。而世界上积极向技术提问的人数并不是全部在线人口。你知道，世界上大约有80亿人，其中40亿在线。
全球约80亿人，其中40亿在线。消费者应用的大致经济规模是：Alphabet有约40亿用户，每人每年变现约100美元；Meta有约35亿用户，每人每年变现约70美元。
Meta有约35亿用户，每年每用户变现约70美元。领先的AI供应商ChatGPT有约10亿用户，每年每用户变现约10美元。问题是如何将10亿用户提升到40亿？我不确定知识工作就是答案，我认为必须超越知识工作。
将10亿提升到40亿？我不确定知识工作就是答案，我们需要超越知识工作。第二个问题是如何将每用户每年10美元提升到100美元？我不确定订阅是答案，我怀疑必须转向广告，而ChatGPT或Cloud能提供的广告定价会更好，因为它们能理解你的意图。
我不确定订阅是答案，我怀疑必须转向广告，而ChatGPT或Cloud能提供的广告定价会更好，因为它们能理解你的意图。你会登录，因此有很好的归属，更多的信任。我认为这将是今年的另一个大新闻，你们是第一个听到的。
你会登录，因此有很好的归属，更多的信任。我认为这将是今年的另一个大新闻，你们是第一个听到的。理解广告模型会带来很多价值。
再次回到10年前Facebook IPO时，有很多看空报告，因为人们说：“嘿，广告在电脑上有效，在手机上不一定有效。”为什么？因为手机上没空间。结果我们找到了空间。现在同样的事情正在发生，就像我们正在对话，这是非常私人的对话。
因为手机上没空间，结果我们找到了空间。现在同样的事情正在发生，就像我们正在对话，这是非常私人的对话，我不希望被广告打扰。这是核心争论。
我说不准未来会怎样，但我乐观地认为我们会找到方法。我认为这将是这个经济模型的重大解锁。我们稍后会深入探讨。
今年晚些时候还会有嘉宾演讲环节。呃，我还准备了很多页幻灯片。时间到了，谢谢大家。